on earth we have everything we need to
survive air to breathe and food and
water to sustain life it's incredible
the effort that was needed to design
this life support system flying around
the planet aboard the International
Space Station a crew of astronauts from
around the globe capture the wonders of
our world as few can from this unique
vantage point we gain insight into the
impact we have on the environment and
witness what humankind can accomplish
when we work together
the arrival to the space station was
possibly the happiest moment in my life
looking at Earth from space we need to
start to consider ourselves more as crew
member not passengers
to meet you I've been ladies
my best part about being an astronaut is
looking back at our home planet
especially at night the cities are so
bright and so vibrant and so colorful
this is just overwhelming Lee
beautiful island in cooperation with
NASA and bite you aboard the
International Space Station for an
incredible journey
it's a giant universe out there there's
lots of stars lots of planets but
there's nowhere like Orion to explore
the challenges we face and the changes
we can make to secure our future
in the end it's about understanding how
the natural world works and that is
about expanding possibilities of what we
human beings can do
a beautiful planet the voyage begins
April 29th exclusively in IMAX and IMAX
3d theaters